[Music]
you see today's WS press briefing if you
didn't you miss Democratic operatives
posing as reporter stunned by the idea
that mailin voting might not be totally
100% secure it was amusing to watch of
course the risks of mailin voting are
obvious the lest example of that came
today doj announced that the FBI and the
Pennsylvania State Police are
investigating fraud in mail and ballots
in lern County that's a place Donald
Trump won by double digits four years
ago according to doj several military
ballots were quote dis guarded
investigators have recovered a total of
nine ballots so far not surprisingly the
doj says an overwhelming majority of
those ballots were cast for Guess Who
Donald Trump meanwhile in Greenville
Wisconsin authorities announced Tuesday
that three trays of mail including mail
and ballots were discovered in a ditch
not counted in a ditch we've seen other
examples of this throughout the year
including deliberate mail and ballot
fraud in New Jersey and in West Virginia
just hours ago in the state of Texas the
State Attorney General announced that a
County Commissioner and several others
have been arrested in an organized mail
and balloting scheme took place during
the 2018 Democratic primary but to
reporters in Washington this is
impossible to believe for the people
doing it it is confirmation that
actually it works pretty well last week
judges on Pennsylvania Supreme Court
ruled that mailin ballots need to be
counted well after election day you
won't be shocked to know that five
members of the body that made that
decision five out of seven people on the
Supreme Court of Pennsylvania are
partisan Democrats they're elected
they're
politicians last week in the state of
Michigan a judge called Cynthia Diane
Stevens issued a very similar ruling in
fact she went farther she mandated
ballot harvesting ballot harvesting
allows paid political operatives to
collect ballots in bundles and bring
them to polling places what could go
wrong well fraud for one thing in fact
Fraud's the whole point of it you should
know that cythia Dian Stevens is not
much of a judge she's a political
activist you often hear conservatives
dered activist judges but that's not
overstatement in this case Cynthia Dian
Stevens is proud to be an activist four
years ago she appeared at an event at
the University of Michigan on equity and
inclusion and she literally gave the
crowd advice on how to Be an Effective
activist not judge activist it's on
video if you want to find it there's
nothing partisan judges would like to
destroy more in the end than a quick
efficient fraud-free election night
that's the goal here make no mistake if
all the votes are counted in one night
no one will have time to issue rulings
that throw out ballots they don't like
that's why judges in Pennsylvania and
Michigan want pole workers to count
votes for weeks after election day with
their rulings last week they made that
essentially inevitable it'll be a
disaster we know that for certain we've
seen it before during the Iowa caucuses
this past February we still don't really
know who won in Iowa today 7 months
later but to leaders of the democratic
party the caucuses weren't a debacle
they were a blueprint for the president
presential election where Joe Biden
takes Hillary Clinton's advice and does
not concede no matter what happens all
he has to do is smile and wave from his
hotel room on Election night and the
lawyers will take it from there that's
the plan